Hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel. In this video, I decided to
share with you my worst trading session
of the month. We are qualified for the
worst session of the week. Every
movement got absorbed in the first two
hours. This is the worst market
condition you can get for my strategy.
Like up, you try the breakout da da da
da da. You can take 10 stop loss. It's
getting momentum down and we are in
profit of $7,000. Look at this. Look how
much it's accelerating. $9,000 in profit
again. Look at this session, bro.
Impossible to trade like this. Just
impossible. And we are going long again.
So out there, everyone is eager to share
the best performance, the best session.
But I decided that the first session of
live trading that you will see in my
channel will be a really difficult
session. I went in deep draw down. I
took a streak of stop-loss and I manage
risk without overexposing my account.
And this video will be on mental
discipline and how to manage a day in
draw down. And if you watch till the
end, you will see that even session like
this can be managed properly and can be
turned in a profitable day. Big buyers
getting absorbed on the top. Today there
is a lot of volume. So I need to bigger
filter. These buyers still show up on
this one. Let's see if we can do it. We
can do something interesting. So guys,
what's happening here is that we got the
most consolidation session of the month.
It's the precession of the 23. It got
consolidating for all the session. Now
we are in a super consolidating area in
the last two hours. So my trend
following model took a straight stop
loss. We are at $9,000 in draw down for
the day. We have one short short that is
floating $3,500
in profit with the potential to make
$15,000 on the short way because the
buyers now switched to short. But the
problem is that we are still
consolidating. So it's it's qualified to
be one of the most boring session not of
the week but of the month. What we can
do is manage risk correctly, accept a
day of draw down if the condition don't
get better and also decide to take some
profit to reduce the amount of draw down
if necessary. We will see if the market
does a good breakdown on the level
24,932
for a capitulation down and I will
update you at the end of the session on
how this is going.
[Music]
again. Look at this session, bro.
Impossible to trade like this. Just
impossible. Now we are going long again.
The volume is building on the short
side. So I'm still of the same idea, but
really this is qualified as the worst
session of the of the month. most boring
one and impossible to trade. One
position management. This is mindset
management.
[Music]
Not even an asset. It's just consolid
constant consolidation. Now, I hope that
the sellers on the up part will get
really aggressive and finally we will
break. But it was a [__] hard
session. Even if I make $2,000, this is
a session where you usually do damage on
your account because it's just getting
on your nerve. There is no RAM. Look
what it's doing. The only positive stuff
is that with this movement, I can put
risk to almost zero. If it accept and
scale inside other two contract maybe
this is the only positive stuff. Let's
see what we can do. We can scale other
two contract here on the way down.
[Music]
Set up here the stop loss $600 and
profit target. Let me scale two contract
because the draw down is contained
[Music]
and also put stop loss to zero. So we
don't risk. If we can get finally a pop
down, we will not only recover
everything but finish the day with
$7,000.
One of this garbage day. So this will be
qualified as the worst session of the of
the month, not of the week. Just bad
luck that we got so good session
yesterday and today that I wanted to
record for my channel. It's
[Music]
even if it's a cheap price action in the
meaning that it's boring as [__] it
seems that it's building some it's
moving faster at least. I don't know
which direction because it's hard to
predict when the market is like this.
But seems like something interesting.
Our profit target is not even too far
from there. So let's see if the sellers
can finally protect it gain up. What
does it mean? It means that if we can
break this low, this horizontal level,
probability that we go down it's
exponential. If we break this one, the
probability that we go up, it's
exponential. It's really not a tighter.
It's stressful this profession. Imagine
if if you can lose $10,000 in one day.
You can you can handle it. It's risky.
The market gets aggressive to arrive
here. It's not so difficult. Just we
need a little bit of gentle explosion.
When the market is like this, the only
bubbles that you need
are the one that you have. It's bubbles.
It's but we we break through the level
again again again.
So it's not only consolidating outside
now it's consolidating inside. So also
in the small ranges you see it's smaller
and smaller and smaller. You don't see a
big explosion. Stressful day bro. One of
the most stressful of the month. But
this battle will be an amazing battle
for the channel if we finish like I
think we can finish.
Consider
this like a wall. If you use the maze 10
times here, every time you hit it gets
weaker and weaker and weaker. And if
they eat, it's 4.5 billion short. Means
that the market maker and the hedge fund
are really aggressive on the downside
and they will push the price if they
continue like this. The short side is
still the most probable. When they
decide to approach the level, you will
not see ta da. You will see
so fast that this number scales by,000
multiple. I see.
>> So it's like 5, 6, 9, 8, 10. Okay. So
from 6,000 you see 7,000 like this
6,600.
Then when I finish, I will comment the
the session. If it goes good, if it goes
bad, it's not a problem. like we will
comment what it's really happening here.
Fusing a game for the 1,000 time.
You know when they say it's the easiest
profession on the planet because you can
make money from home. Yeah. They say
trading it so it's the most difficult.
In the next run we push and down and
then we go up and down up and down. I
like what he's doing. I like a lot what
he's doing. Ooh, we are in profit.
$5,000 and I think we are ready to
[__]
But now the battle is won by the
sellers. So we can see this level
approached and I think now the sellers
will win. So we will go to the next one.
It's like video games, you know. And the
next one is this.
But if this gets broken, we have a
collapse down. So we go to take profit.
Try my best to predict bread. But
sometimes it's just unpredictable what
the market does. But you cannot predict
when it will go choppy. If I can predict
when it will go like this, I will be
billionaire. It's not just choppies.
It's after this huge movement down
choppy. So the probability is that these
sellers will continue to push this
market down, you know, because they have
already all the position here. So when
the price reach this they will again say
oh I want to add more because I'm making
money. And you can see here they have
4.7 billion almost $5 billion short
possible day guys.
[Music]
But look at this 18 contract from the
top with risk-to-reward 1 to 20. Look at
this the sniper on the now. Now it will
take the low end. We go.
>> So what I expect now is an acceleration
down. We are already recovering all the
draw down. This is the best the best
lesson on how to handle a draw down day.
It was really the worst session of the
month. We took a huge amount of stop-
loss in this compression area. Let's see
if we can recover everything with one
good trade. We are accelerating down
floating 10,000 in profit. Let's see
what we can do. Now the market maker are
long gamma. So they will try to compress
volatility. I expect a good explosion
down. We are going $12,000 in profit. I
can also close the day with $12,000 in
profit, but I expect breakdown. Maybe I
put stop in profit to recover all the
draw down. Volatility is starting to
kick in. We are below the low. The next
candle can accelerate and sweep. Okay,
we are going
[Music]
$13,000 in profit.
We are going.
Momentum is starting to kick in. Let's
see. See how it goes. Let's follow the
price. I don't want to put too much
pressure on expectation to go down
because it's still long gamma. So, the
role is to compress this movement.
Floating $13,000.
Here we go. Here we go. See if we can
break the low
again. Sellers entering aggressive. We
are going to protect ourself soon here.
Okay, we locked in $12,000 and we are
out of the position. So, a day that was
in negative 9,000 is going to be closing
2,330.
Done. Okay, we saved everything and we
still made 10,000 for the day. This is
the draw down of the day. We've been all
the day in draw down. This is the
positive side. You can see that even if
you go through a huge amount of stop-
loss during the day, your only role is
to endure during all these moments and
get the movement that create a new
range. This is the only way to I don't
want to say to be profitable every week
but to have a huge amount of probability
that you will be profitable with control
loss and amazing profit. So the
conclusion guys, now we have been a
little bit uh too much on the safe side
because the market is collapsing now and
we could have made $7,000 of profit
more. So we could end the day at 9,000.
But when the day starts really bad and
the compression it's so bad, even if the
option is confirming, if even if you
have order flow confirming down, it's
always bad to cut in profit and stop the
day because as soon as you go to the
evening, your focus lowers because you
are sitting on 20 execution and the
market finally is trending. But remember
that when you are positive gamma, they
are going to compress every movement. So
now they can just go up again and you
get in deep depression. So take what the
markets gives you is not the day to
trade trend following. And even in the
worst session of the month, we made
money.